for example one here we've got log base
7 of the 4th root of this whole quantity
so how do we expand that ok well let's
see the first thing that you can think
of is when you have the 4th root that's
really like the one fourth power so let
me just go over here and write that a
little bit differently log base seven x
squared Y cubed over Z to the one fourth
power
now when you have a power to a power you
remember this from when you learned
about exponents you can distribute that
power into the parentheses so power to
power you multiply the exponents so what
we can do now is we can write this as
log base 7 of X to the 2/4 which is
actually one-half Y to the 3/4 all over
Z to the 1/4 okay now what we're gonna
do is you can see these two quantities
in the numerator see how they're
multiplied together so what we can do is
we can write this as a sum like it's a
log base 7 of X to the one-half plus log
base seven Y to the 3/4 and then see how
we're dividing by Z to the 1/4 so that's
the quotient property so we're going to
be subtracting log base 7 of Z to the
1/4 now what we're gonna do is we're
going to take these powers we're gonna
bring them down in front of the logs
okay has coefficients that's the power
property so we're gonna bring that 1/2
down so we get 1/2 log base 7 of x plus
3/4 log base 7 of Y minus 1/4
log base whoops log base 7 of Z and
that's fully expanded right there so
that's the ID you want to just keep
expanding it you can write it as a sum
or difference of logs so let's go to
example 2 now so this one same kind of
idea but what I'm going to do here is
I'm going to rewrite this a little bit
so instead of writing this as up the
square root of x let's think about it as
X to the 1/2 power
so when we distribute this 3 in here
okay like so
okay what we get is we get a log base 5
of X to the 1/2 raised to the third
power that's 1/2 times 3 that's X to the
rehabs right why to the six coz two
times three over W cubed Z to the
fifteenth okay so now you can see how
these two quantities are multiplied
together so we can write this as a sum
so we're going to write this as the log
base 5 of X to the three halves plus a
log base five y to the sixth - okay now
notice see how we're dividing by this
quantity so I'm gonna write this as
minus log base five of W cubed times Z
to the fifteenth okay so now you can do
this you know some students are really
good they can do this all in one step
but I'm just showing you step by step
now notice how these are multiplied
together these two quantities right here
so that means that we can write this as
a sum so log base five of W cubed plus
log base five of Z to the fifteenth
right okay but notice see how this minus
is on the outside of the parentheses
what we can do is we can then distribute
that negative into the parentheses like
that or another way to think of that is
anything that's in the denominator when
you go to expand it that log that
particular log is going to be subtracted
okay anything that's in the numerator
that particular log is gonna be a
positive or you're just going to be
added okay so an easy way to think of it
so let's kind of continue with this so
let's bring these powers now down in
front okay so what I'm gonna do is I'm
going to write this as three halves
log base 5 of X plus 6 log base 5 of y
minus 3 log base 5 of W minus 15 log
base 5 of Z and that's it right there
fully expanded and you've got it so I
hope that helped you understand how to
expand logs better I'll put a link to
another video that I did talking about
expanding logs if you want more practice
and then lastly you know if you're
preparing for the AC T or the SAT check
out my to review courses my two video
review courses once called the huge AC T
math review video course now the other
one is called the huge SAT math review
video course and I go through you know
teach
and example problems and formulas and
things that you're going to want to know
to be well-prepared for that test and
I've got three free lessons for both of
those courses so you can check those out
and see if it's a good fit for you
you'll get something out of those
lessons that will help you you know
boost your score on those tests and
definitely check those out otherwise I
look forward to seeing you in the future
videos and I'll talk to you soon